is it possible to make a billboard
number one song in 30 seconds recently
people have started speedrunning hit
songs where you compete to see who can
recreate the beat the fastest one of the
most popular challenges is Soulja Boy's
Crank That from 2007. first people
started bragging about recreating the
beat in two minutes then one minute then
33.76 seconds
[Music]
the practice of speed running comes from
video games and it's not a coincidence
that people started speedrunning Crank
That Crank That was created on the
software FL Studio and the developer
behind FL Studio is actually a video
game developer DDA Dam Brandt is the
award-winning game developer that
created FL Studio in 1997 FL Studio is
known for being really easy to use
Danbury himself calls it an app for
cheaters so these days just like
speedrunning a video game producers can
make beats faster than ever